the jogan experience and they were
talking about uh what they would do for
significant significant cultural event I
say let me see if I could this is new
policy going in effect February 2024
clearly defines what constitutes a quote
sensitive event for purposes of
prohibiting certain exploitative or
insensitive ads and content yeah that's
it well Google already had policies in
place for ads and YouTube monetization
this expands the restrictions to
Google's publisher Network as well and
so there was it was defined in a certain
way see if you could pull up what it
actually says cuz the way it was defined
what Disturbed me was that it's very
blanket a sensitive event is Dei defined
rather as an unforeseen or unexpected
situation that poses significant risk to
Google's ability to provide highquality
relevant information while reducing
insensitive insensitive content is that
I have a concern with that insensitive
content in prominent and monetized
features insensitive cont insensitive to
who exactly so open and subjective now
listen to this though sensitive events
include those with major social cultural
or political impact such as civil
emergencies natural disasters Public
Health crisises terrorism conflict or
mass violence so what they're saying is
you must be
sensitive if you're going to discuss
civil emergencies natural disasters
Public Health crisises any with a major
social cultural or political impact
terrorism Mass violence you must now be
sensitive the thing is like whatever
they're trying to say and whatever
they're trying to do to make uh the the
the online World a nicer place you got
to be really careful with saying things
like that because sensitive is a weird
term if someone is violently opposed to
who right also if someone is violently
opposed to something that's happening
like think about one one or many of the
military conflicts around the world
don't pick a side what if someone is
violently opposed to these people dying
and losing their lives and they're
talking about it is that an insensitive
piece of content that can now be
censored by a new policy is that what it
is or is they just going to demonetize
it which they've kind of always done I
think this was talking about people who
are making ads using their platform not
people who are hosting content on their
platforms I I say it again I got to
admit I'm a little lost on this one I
think so if any of the listeners out
there are also a little confused is the
no it's about them having the ability to
censor you so if you do the Ron White
Show on YouTube which is owned by Google
if they decide that this something of
whatever you're doing is in somehow or
another offensive they would want to
edit it I don't know what they're saying
they can and can't do I think it's
making ads I don't know if it has to do
with the content that again that's on
YouTube I think this policy content
change is for people who use the Google
ads platform and create ads like this
one I'm showing you right here so that
you can't abuse it you can't monetize it
but look how it's phrase please go go
back to the top sentence so look at
which one it says the updated policy
provides practic including price gouging
misdirected traffic and victim blaming
during sensitive events I'm with the
first ones price gouging misdirected
traffic I'm with those but victim
blaming during sensitive events that one
gets touchy cuz like what do we it's
just using the ads though it's like
making some weird ad to pop up to get
you to click on something that's going
to pop up on content that might be about
that event or anything like that I
understand but Vic blaming the thing
about victim blaming is you can do it
both ways right like victim blaming like
with Hamas and Palestine and and Israel
you could go you could Vic and blame on
both sides you could say the Israelis
were doing this and that's why Hamas had
to attack and you say Hamas attacked and
that's why the Israelis are doing this
and you [__] people should have known
better and you [__] people should
have known better that's victim blaming
sure you got to let people talk yeah and
if talking looks like victim blaming
until people work it out then why not
let you can't just stop people from
talking so what are we saying are we
saying that it's just they can't
monetize that well then what happens is
if you're not monetizing stuff you let
people know that unless they self-censor
it's going to cost them
financially even if the ads like like
say if the represents a company that is
actually interested in this discussion
and wants to know like what is the right
what's the right perspective on this
who's most informed who's looking at
this the most correctly if you're a
company and you're why wouldn't you want
to advertise on something where people
are just talking about what may or may
not be happening in the world and if
you're going to do that on YouTube then
you have to worry about you're losing
your ability to make a living now it's
like is that what happens I don't know I
don't know I mean is this this is just a
blanket policy in in case of the most
egregious offenses that all people agree
are terrible and should probably not be
okay but then who gets to decide that
what happened to the frogs eating the
mouse and [__] like that Ron White this
is the future of people being able to
talk [__] that's what it is no I believe
that you know it's kind of the future of
people being able to talk [__] because
this is how it goes away right it goes
away through stuff like that sure it
goes away through people deciding that
something's insensitive which is like
98% of all jokes right yeah you don't
want to come to my want to come to my
show that's what I'm saying here's their
examples they give okay here's some
examples all right violations dis okay
what is examples exhaustive ads that
claim victims of oh ads that claim
victims of sensitive event responsible
for their own tragedy or similar
instances of victim okay ads so it's
just about ads yeah at least for now it
is you know maybe they could switch it
and be like now all content but well
that's completely reasonable if it's
just about ads that's completely
reasonable yeah I guess you should want
to be able to control how [__] up the
ads are because that's kind of well is
it it's just sad there just like you can
still use other parts of the internet
that can still you can't use propaganda
you can't lie you can't use Google ads
which is the biggest part of the
Internet advertising world right they
shut you out do it somewhere else that's
all they're saying right that's seems
reasonable yeah that's pretty reasonable
as long as they're not doing that with
the actual content of the the the
podcast because I do know that they
demonetize they demonetize people all
the time if you talk about certain
subjects it's it's always been a problem
this is yeah this is don't do that to
you they used to do it yeah they used to
do it up until the time when we switched
over to Spotify they start website this
is specifically on Advertising policiy
so now they don't do it to anybody or
they no no they do it to other people
they do it to other people all the time
but they stopped doing it to us for like
three months like where they didn't give
us any dings we're doing the same show
right I don't know any other way to do
this you got to sit down and talk [__]
it's the only way to do it if I change
that for somebody that's going to censor
something or I'm going to lose money
like what are you talking about like I
can't change what I do no I zero
interest in doing that yeah you know and
if I don't think it's offensive then
that's it that's the end of the
conversation and I think you're pretty
sensitive yeah I'm sensitive I try to be
sensitive about these kind of things
it's just you got to let people talk and
just because people disagree with you it
doesn't mean there's something wrong
with
them